irène chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport
c'est une gare une gare comme toutes les
gares avec parfois des voyageurs
imprévus elle a des trains bien sûr et
ses princes nous emporte la ou les
heures semble ne jamais finir où la
nature a hobo lit le règne de la nuit au
pays du soleil de minuit
vous voulez tout de suite savoir comment
est ce pays on me soyez patient qui
arriveront tout à l'air je sais la
patience amène parfois la déception mais
la déception est une expérience alors
pourquoi pas
on se croirait en suisse ou en autriche
je viens pas du tout en étant chouette
la barque du dimanche
pour lui les villageois à l'office la
coutume exige là bas et il n'y a rien de
plus tyranniques qu'une coutume vous
savez la coutume disait exige que là bas
il porte pour aller à la messe le
costume traditionnel les femmes sont
coquettes et c'est très bien ainsi
et celles ci ont tout l'interminable
hiver pour broder ces jolies choses non
ce n'est pas une gravure ancienne pas du
tout là bas on apprécie beaucoup ce
qu'ils travaillaient en laine naturelle
le geste précédent appelé forcément
celui ci
l'hiver une fait très froid mais l'été
s'il ne fait pas très très chaud les
prairies ont tous le même droit à leur
jonché fleurs mais oui il pourra presque
citerne
c'est une boîte aux lettres son
propriétaire doit vivre à des kilomètres
de là dans la nature ou peut-être en
voyage t-il beaucoup si les flotteurs de
bois par exemple les arbres et l'eau
sont les deux principales ressources de
la suède
les flotteurs de bois appartiennent à
une sorte d'aristocratie des
travailleurs ceux qui sont libres d'y
vivre en perpétuelle communion avec la
nature qui reconnaissent ses moindres
signes et les interprètes
comme le plus souvent à la belle étoile
coulé dans une couverture ou pré daf
casier il baptise les étoiles et raconte
leur histoire au vent ou aux animaux
tapis dans l'ombre qu'il devine sans les
voir car ils ont presque autant
d'instinct que si la forêt ne les
accepte pas alors inutile pour eux de
poursuivre et jean les empêcheront
travaillé par mille moyens et par contre
s'ils arrivent à se faire accepter ces
mêmes ou jean leur montrerons touche que
nous ne savons pas et qu'ils n'ont pas
le droit à nous dire c'est un étrange
métier que celui de flotteurs du bois il
faut être poète philosophe et ça c'est
un métier dangereux mais pourquoi pas
dangereux les plus beaux métiers
comporte le plus souvent une grande part
de risque
ici nous sommes arrivés à la frontière
de notre voyage c'est la porte du cercle
polaire
oui ce poteau nous l'indiquent
et ce certificat est bien ce certificat
nous servira à épater nos amis voilà
seclin de faire rien de kirina certains
d'entre vous se rappellent peut être le
voyage que nous avons fait il ya
quelques temps dans cette ville
extraordinaire perdu près du cercle
polaire
vous voyez en plein été ou cercle
polaire il ne fait pas bien chaud
la vie est simple
un pêche beaucoup
l'omble chevalier le saumon la truite
tous des poissons très fin
les fermes de montagne sont absolument
solitaire et petits enfants se déguisent
là-bas déjà en lapin
et voici le but du voyage le pays lapin
ils vivent dans des camps en perpétuel
déplacement pour permettre à leurs
troupeaux de paître ses termes éthiques
étanche et pratique et vous allez le
voir ça se balancent très bien
des écoles itinérant suivre les enfants
pour leur permettre de faire des études
pas trop trop décousu
un bon coup pen fait toujours un joli
garçon
en récréation on s'entraîne à faire
comme papa et le grand frère on attache
une paire de cornes sur le copain et on
essaie d'attraper le tout haut le saut
ils fabriquent leurs objets leurs
ustensiles usuels à la main dans
différentes matières depuis le bois
jusqu'à la corne de rennes et le plein
hiver et là alors c'est l'heure de la
grande épopée
c'est l'heure de la chasse
on part il faut partir car de la chasse
dépend la vie les troupeaux suis
non ce n'est pas une image fixe il se
braque comme ça quelquefois car
paraît-il il semble déjà venir de très
loin les premiers effluves du printemps